Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
We've mentioned that it is a strong
we've mentioned a few narrations of
the prophet sallall.aii Wasam
that
clearly state the inherent dangers of
a person abandoning his prayer of a
person either abandoning his prayer or
not taking his prayer seriously.
We have
that the author has told us here related
to us a number of narrations regarding
this issue.
The prophet sallall.aii wasallam tells
us
that what stands between a man
and disbelief itself
and polytheism shik is the abandonment
of salah.
Likewise our prophet sallall.aii
Wasallam tells us
the allegiance and different
differentiating
quality between us and them is salah.
And so whoever abandons it, this person
has fallen into disbelief.
Likewise, our prophet
sallall.aii alaihi wasallam
has told us that whoever
exalts, holds in high esteem the five
daily prayers that Allah has commanded,
takes them seriously
and holds them with reverence,
then this person will have an promise, a
solemn promise from Allah to admit
commit him into paradise.
So he tells us
[Silence]
He says five prayers Allah has obligated
upon his servants.
Whoever fulfills these five prayers and
does not lose any of them
out of
a lack of exaltation of their esteem
and does not squander any of them out of
a lack of reverence for this obligation.
This person has
an obligation and a promise from Allah
that he will admit him into paradise.
And then he tells us the opposite is
true. That whoever does lose any of
these prayers and does not fulfill them
and does not take them seriously has no
promise from Allah to admit him into
paradise.
We look at salah.
We mentioned that the serious position
of salah and the reason why salah
specifically out of all of the different
obligations in Islam has this potent
danger in it is because of the frequency
of the disobedience.
person is commanded five times a day. At
every moment in your day, there is
essentially a prayer which is expected
of you. And if you do not fulfill this
prayer, you are in disobedience of Allah
if you do not make that prayer. El was
commanded to pray to make how many
prayers that he disobeyed Allah when he
told him to prostrate to Adam.
How many prayers? How manyawat?
One sagd.
Just one saga.
And he refused. And Allah deemed him
what?
Allah judged him of the disbelievers for
doing so. So how much more so the issue
of a person who insists on abandoning
prayer day and night very dangerous.
Very very very dangerous.
And the four m
of the four imams, they differ on
whether or not a person who abandons
salah
is even still a Muslim.
This is how serious abandoning salah is.
Now this is not for us to
deem people Muslim or non-Muslim. That's
the position for the scholars of Islam
who speak on behalf of Allah and his
messenger. However, the point here is
that this is not a light matter.
And the mhab of Imam Ahmed, the madhab
of Imam Malik,
a person who has thoroughly abandoned
salah is to be
is to be and then dies upon death is
not to be prayed upon, not to be
shrouded or buried with the Muslim.
This is how serious the scholars take
this. The least of the in seriousness is
the of Abuhanifh
with respect to someone who abandons
prayer. You know what he said? He said a
person who has abandoned prayer is to be
locked up in prisoned and beaten re
until he prays and if he does not
remains in prison. This is how serious
the scholars take this. And so we must
equally know that prayer is paramount.
If you do not instill the importance of
prayer in your children, you are
you are not fulfilling your duty. The
greatest duty that a parent has is to
instill the religion
that Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala sent down
into his children and to impress upon
them the importance of the Quran and the
importance of salah. These are the two
main things. The author shares with us a
final narration in this chapter before
he moves on to the technicalities of
prayer. You know the technicalities, the
conditions and the obligations and the
pillars and breaks it down in that way.
He mentions a narration that I believe
many of us have not heard before. We're
not familiar with. It's a well-known
narration amongst the scholars of
hadith. It's been collected by
in his on the authority of
[Silence]
th
said, "The messenger of Allah
Sallallah.aii wasallam has said Islam
can will continue to fade
just the colors of a garment.
Meaning when it's repeatedly worn and
washed, you see the colors fade out of
it. said Islam's
Islam's hallmarks and rights
in in the world and amongst the Muslim
will continue to fade and become more
and more weak just the colors of a
garment fade.
He said and this fading of Islam and its
pillars and the knowledge of Islam not
amongst disbelievers amongst Muslim will
continue to fade over time meaning in
the end days right before the day of
judgment will continue to fade until
even the Muslim will not know what
fasting is they will not know what salah
is. They will not know what Omrah is.
They will not know what charity is.
What happens when this occurs? Why does
this happen? First of all, is it because
people don't have knowledge or access to
knowledge? They'll still have the Quran.
Correct? And it has all these things in
it. The reason is people will
practice less and less. They will be
take their religion less and less
seriously until it becomes widespread
that this is no longer common knowledge
amongst the Muslim.
He says, "And when that happens,"
he said, "And then one night the Quran
will be lifted from the earth until
there is no longer a single verse on the
earth.
person will go to open a mus and it is
just white pages nothing there and not
one person on earth has a single verse
of the Quran anymore
this is the book of Allah as a gift when
humanity collectively does not take it
seriously what happens takes it back if
a person memorizes the Quran and then
doesn't practice it constantly what
happens forget it Allah takes it back.
He takes it back, right?
He says,"He
said, "And after this happens, there
will remain pockets of people here and
there throughout the earth, old men and
old women who remember the old world,
that will say,
We remember, we vaguely remember our
parents, our forefathers used to
sayahillah.
So we say it as they said it that will
be the epitome of Islam upon the earth.
He says so when said this to one of his
students
is one of students.
He said, "Of what consequence
willahillah
be for them if they do not know what
salah is or fasting or what and omrah
are or what charity is. Of what
consequence is this only word?
[Silence]
He said,
"And so
did not respond to this question. He
ignored it." And Sah continued to ask it
until he asked her three times about
this. And in the third time, Hifa turned
to him and said, "Oh Silah,
this word will be of consequence to them
that it will save them from the fire."
And he said this to him three times.
Just like
the very beginning, very very very
beginning when
was the only verses of the Quran.
What was the epitome of practicing Islam
at that time?
There was no salah. There was no
fasting. There was nothing yet. Correct?
And as a matter of fact,
He died upon that, right? That's what he
died upon. That that is the epitome of
Islam that he had
known.
And so
as the prophet sallall.aii Wasam said
that Islam
started out strange and the minority and
it will return to being strange and
unheard of as it began. And this will be
this is an evidence that is discussed
amongst the scholars for the argument
that a person who abandons salah does
not completely leave Islam. However,
these people, this is a poor argument
because these people do not have access
to salah for them to abandon it. It's
completely gone. And so the only thing
they have access to isahill. So they say
it. So because they say it, it will save
them from the fire.
be in a Muhammad.
[Silence]
[Arabic recitation]